and by interaction number right what the
hell was that from stingray yeah because
we're in a mess of Thunderbirds thing
for a while then we tried something
right but okay scary oh yeah there's
that sort of fishes and the fish people
creepy yeah the boys loved all that
marionette stuff you know anything you
could do back in the old days of Jerry
and Sylvia Anderson to avoid walking
it's clever conveyor belt to take you
somewhere and if you're in Wellington do
the the Thunderbirds experience at the
widow workshop and they take you through
the the miniature sets that they built
for the reimagine series and it's really
cool very very faithful yeah we have to
take the boys at some point actually
probably not the first time so go
reconnoiter just you and Phil the first
time so you can take it in instead of at
500 questions yeah what's this I need to
go to the toilet
come on in are we live we certainly are
awesome thank you
[Applause]
even have you got a mute on your end
all righty people I think what's this on
five past three so your detonator mihika
kato thank you for joining us this
afternoon for the Smeg meeting welcome
everybody
I see we've got media here and we live
streaming to the world so please let's
all be on her best behavior this
afternoon
Roger you not like your pilot yeah I
just hear Bureau seized on yeah go ahead
and open the meeting this afternoon and
call for apologies I can see we haven't
got green yeah she was going to attend
in person and then when I checked today
and found out was the meeting was solely
by zoom I mentioned that to marina or a
marina was going to try and contact
green so I'm not sure what's happened
about that okay so I'm just gonna put
down an apology for green at the stage
and maybe fleck marina and critiques
just to make sure that geez oh here we
go
apologies for lateness from green and
she'll be with us in about ten minutes
so it's good and we are missing someone
else
Christine Henderson I believe so I hit
head no apology so I'll just might bed
in is an apology and we'll move on as
the any other apologies okay um interest
register just the same unusual if you
needed it to be updated to send your
information through the administrative
team and we'll move straight into the
minutes of mass meeting you know I'm
happy to move that those are incorrect
thank you capsule allowed my in thanks
Evelyn sickening next all those in favor
chameleon hand wave against carriage
that's perfect
moving to the action sheet obviously we
are still waiting to determine the
outcome of Dame Kiri Te Kanawa I can
tell you that I have reached out and I'm
still waiting a response so we'll
continue to do that for the opening and
Kimberly have we any update on that
here's a report been achieved no worries
thank you very much and as you will know
we've had that report from mr. Horner
read the roof so I'm going to move to
take there off the action sheet and with
those amendments if anyone else have
anything additional to add to that it
would be great if not we'll move that
the bottom section comes off the sheet
in the three above remain all those in
favor great against carries it's
wonderful and our items for review is
just a standard document so that we know
we are keeping up and keeping on top of
everything and up-to-date with
everything so we are on target for
everything at this present point in time
I'll move to the reports for today's
meeting and mirrors three on our agenda
so I'll ask David and Kimberly firstly
to take us through the snags management
reports accurate equal to a in terms of
collections team the report just goes
through some of the achievements they
made during the lockdown period so we
had a very productive the two guys
obviously set up their workshop at home
and got through 15
it's a huge lot of Dover's which in its
effective throes of the little aluminum
brackets hold our paintings and to our
friends 189 corners so the just
treatment GFO they lock an out big
furniture onto the pallets without
spending too much money to do it which
is really good and then some of the pay
dirt materials or collection items they
also worked on that and then earrin
assistant registrar worked on Kurt's
collection so that was his work that was
done as part of a series of exhibitions
the first one being here
does he come on being an Auckland in the
third one and just being at Dunedin
public art galleries so all that data
that had been gathered during that
period was entered onto our database so
huge achievement
just prior to lock down we got through
the process of imaging all our
paper-based accession registers so we
did the gate receipts last year having
that the registers kind of checks off
that final thing that if something
happens to this building we still have
all that data secured so now it's all
digital as well and we work through a
few collections of a Sorensen collection
is a very large collection that came to
us in the 1940s he was a director for a
period so we just had one staff member
working through just ticking that what
we have on our database matches what he
has in his registers of it we've met
chuckle the provenance so just making
sure that they connect people in places
and there were quite a few that we enter
on the database so that future picture
project to work through we've been
through 3,300 acquisition data chips so
that involves again it's about making
sure that our collection items are
connected to people and that you know
opening up the world that those name is
Lee
into going through our wildlife permits
dentists so just making sure that
everything that we've Kim longs to date
links into one of the permit categories
which is really important and will help
us in our reporting to dock in
particular we upgraded the place
database both to make sure that all the
places were accurate and that they both
had identified in both English as gnarly
and quietly in the background we're
still working on our repatriation
preparedness project and as a result of
some of the proposed projects that I've
mentioned 12 additional modified remains
were identified and a bit of research
into the provenance so that we added
them to their final report to be we we
progress that project and then unis the
building in the tuatara and Zeke's wood
sheets daily during lockdown we
responded to two leaks in the roof they
went we work very well prepared for them
that wasn't an issue in our HVAC system
decided to have a little tantrum during
lockdown but it was spectacle please and
thank you
so from an Operations point of view the
social media posts we've been putting up
on South Museum in a queue Larry and
hello Kazuya about being populist
Henry's 50th anniversary at the Museum
reached Russia I think it's up to almost
$6,000 5,000 when we wrote this and
released the branding for Hill Walker to
you let's in a great great amount of
take-up from the public it's easier over
500 followers and that wasn't the first
relief for us I think we're closer to
700 now so people are really interested
really keen to get engaged so we're
really excited about there as far as the
curators we've been pretty busy working
from home it was a lot of planning a lot
of writing creating content and
developing programs for the new space
since since returning we've been getting
ready to install the first exhibition
with the help of their wider team with
the Corrections team with the reparative
so we imagine this will take about
between sort of 8 19 weeks to get this
installed rust removal so once we get
the once or the network and all the IDs
and the space we'll be able to move in
and start installing this first
exhibition there are a few things from
Australia so there may be some delays in
international shipping but we hope that
it won't be too much for the 18 week
anyway also during the last part of
lockdown Lindsay was able to provide the
ICC living species team extra assistance
I think we made a character that was
chewing on something that shouldn't have
been and Lindsay was able to advise ways
to stop said character from destroying
bits and pieces in a very yeah but other
than that were being fed up with them
emails photography research requests and
all the usual sorts of things that we do
here seems really positive we're looking
forward to the future it's awesome thank
you guys just to express our sincere
gratitude towards all the work that you
guys have been doing in the background
there and I know it's never recognised
on a regular basis but especially around
the here whakatohea work that everybody
collaboratively along with I peek has
achieved and we've had nothing but
excellent feedback about the design how
sleek and classy it looks and it's
awesome job so thank you um any
questions or team fire
evylyn the remains they take it they've
been transferred to the coyly space I
know we're waiting until Monday so that
you could oh thank you okay we
not going to be in the same place as
their yeah it's a bit of a problem we
might have to go down after sounds good
yeah okay thank you
giving other questions
Sarah I don't need say we didn't mention
in this report but this is the code for
him and Kimberly this is an example
express the south and exclusive running
air how often is it baby
weekly weekly cutie story about staff at
Museum and the really awesome things
they offered to do for the museum and
it's just really really nice in
something that you're going to make sure
the Blue Ox of support around avian
kemberly making sure that can keep
getting there be some interesting
interesting stories coming up in the
next few our Kimberly story in this this
week's one is really cool
fascinating great come on in especially
to beam I have that offer it shows that
the community is wanting to get behind
the transformation of that particular
space and so it's it's awesome
good work any other questions okay out
with it in my min we will move on to the
next item of not after obviously
receiving the port report which I'm
happy to move and I'm sure beaks fear
with her hand up is happy to see Kim for
me so without any any other questions or
discussion all those in favor of
receiving net report please give me away
waves we danced against literally yes Oh
couldn't get on a zoom because I need my
upgraded even Italy okay now it's nice
to hear from you I can see your sign
number coming through welcome our fine
thank you just just catching up with
everybody sorry to be so late no it's
completely fine so if you just joined us
Chris we're moving into item number five
on the agenda which is they we've just
moved to that report that we received
the managers report so we're now going
to fire
point toe which was the repurposing smeg
trust board reports thank you Tony
no worries everybody you can see this
report I take it that it's been read so
in our last meeting we had a discussion
around what the potential repurposed
Smeg trust board could look like and it
was appropriate that we gave information
considering we have been the kaitiaki of
the collection for some time it's
important that we contribute what we
feel would be useful for the collection
moving forward and there's been a number
of emails toing and froing
these recommendations have come out over
reports and it was drafted by Rogers I
think she Roger for that time that
you've put into this and it's really a
discussion point we do not need to pass
recommendations today if we don't feel
the need to but there is a good place to
start
and I really welcome discussions around
some of the recommendations that are in
front of you so I will open up for
questions
Roger if you want to take some time
maybe to talk to that report very
quickly no sorry excuse me it doesn't
have to be quickly at all just briefed
us on how those discussions come about
then we can move through those
recommendations one at a time yeah thank
you and Tony we earlier the suggestion
was that our board may not survive but
subsequently the expression repurposing
was raised and I was pleased about there
because there then might mean that we
have a continuing function even though
it looks like a completely new board
will ultimately be appointed so the
purpose of this document was to try and
look forward as to what Smeg would do
and especially because under our
existing Constitution functions are not
really spelled out
so in paragraph seven of that discussion
document I tried to set out what would
be the functions of Smeg and I feel that
in this area David and Kimberly could be
very helpful because they may have a
better and more modern understanding of
what the function of Smeg ought to be or
the function of a museum but one of the
things which I did want to do was to
ensure that we stay connected with thee
and the Carol City Council especially so
that if they're if it turns out that we
don't own the building or don't own any
new building that we don't become
divorced from the Invercargill City
Council and that there's an ongoing
connection of purpose between the two of
us and that was sort of the reason for
7g to liaise with the City Council but
otherwise I'm I'm just practicing lawyer
so there will be others around this some
table who will have a better idea about
what what our purposes should be so I'm
very even very Welling myself to listen
to any suggestions about what's made
should be trying to achieve Thank You
Roger
councillor mumbo thanks Tony and thanks
to the work Roger I think it's it's good
that Smeg looks too to see how it can
continue to maintain relevance it was
interesting listening to a discussion at
ICC recently around perhaps further
involvement from the external
organization that they'd be interested
in seeing as well I don't have any great
issue in principle with with any of the
suggestions but the wording around that
puts us as the enabler so it's a job in
the way it's worded to preserve and
maintain to continue to acquire preserve
and interpret whereas I'm not sure who's
going to have the operational funding to
to do this so I wonder if the
the two as the active in it should be
followed with oversee or ensure because
I'm not sure that we can instruct
without without funds I'm not sure yet
whether the the final structure will
involve snake having some funding but
that was my feedback on it thanks Roger
Thank You Council on that blue fire
queen good afternoon welcome along can
you hear us loud and clear yes thank you
a wonderful um Evelyn I couldn't have
got my head around all of us out of what
we have been talking about and probably
it needed his leg Elijah I'm not daring
I think without any without any funds
and we are not we will not be the
employers we will only be not only we
will be Guardians quite you know Turner
to Chiaki or of the Tonga and hips the
language does need to be tweaked to to
be to reflect their in its hell and from
we're the new board would be sourced so
perhaps we need to look at one or two
specific things like an outside Experian
museums or an outside the exhibition
there archaeology or something like that
because they are possibly skills that
we're not going to find from within our
community we may actually have to create
a position on the board to do that to
advise us because the museum staff are
not looking for us they're working for
the council so in order to have our
and dependent advice we may need to look
at whether we saw set by my possessions
on the on the board that was that was my
only thoughts and in terms of you know
but there depends on what council
decides is what they see also the
purpose of the museum ball going forward
whether they have some intentions about
is guarantee at about funding or about
some some form of resourcing that gives
us something more to do than be advisors
thank you thank you
um Biggs thanks um yeah I agree with
what Darren and Evelyn are sort of
saying and I think that what Roger has
put together is a great starting point
for discussion I'm just not sure that we
should be really at this point to adopt
there isn't recommendations which is
what the recommendation is and I'm
wondering I know that the council
resolution talked about talking to the
other councils in the South and regional
heritage committee before going forward
with things and I'm thinking that maybe
we should be doing the same because
despite the fact that we our role is
narrowing to the guardianship of the
collection we are still in partnership
with an IDI we - that actually II we in
the council's in the regional heritage
committee so I think we're probably
better off to have some discussion with
them and work to give that as for these
and I think this is a great place to
start I think it encompasses all the
things that accounts um talked about
with regard to having a skills-based
board and those really important things
but I think that for the detail of it we
probably need to work together with the
council's in the regional here at the
committee in a way to make sure that it
covers all the bases and does what we
need it to do
Thank You weeks um every time I hear for
some reason why
on everybody else I get really nervous
but I hear what you're saying I just
don't want it to get to the point where
we overthink so much that nothing gets
accomplished um Gary yeah thank you
mom please we're all on the same page I
it consumes with the word of dot today I
didn't think we were going to be
adopting it today so that's great and
yeah these project greats that to this
and we are a governance body or a
smegging is it Gavin that's body not a
lot of management role so I think some
of that wording does need to be changed
I'm a bit like Joe that's here on the
concern about waiting but I guess you've
waited long enough now to get where you
are but it would be good to progressed
as as soon as possible and I think what
Rogers done here is it as a fantastic
start to there as long as we can get
agreement as a board to you the
difference between management and
governments is the big one so thank you
thank you Gary I'm hearing that maybe we
happy with with the information that rod
has put together
I'm hearing that we don't want to adopt
recommendations today and that maybe we
need to be sending a formal letter to
for example council councils and
regional heritage with our suggestions
is it fair to ask you today for some
agreement around some of the suggestions
that are being made Tony can I add a
little bit please that's Christine defer
absolutely Cresco Fran thank you are
just reading through the minutes in the
recommendations about repurposing Smeg
chessboard and the Gryphon reporter and
things like that
the the confusion arises for me is
through the assurance that we've got all
the council's working together on this
that there's no confusion between the
Smeg upskilling
its membership plus versus direct or
indirect involvement by the funding
councils
of interested parties in the museum
itself and also what purpose would a
museum director which I assume is part
of the planning for the future what
purposes would that museum director have
what's what would be required of that
person in terms of all the things we're
asking that skills-based Spitz Meg Ward
to do because I have a feeling that some
of these things are going to run into
each other or override each other it
will become confused and I'd like to
think that when a museum director is
finally chosen that that person will
have a team to work with which covers
quite a bit of the stuff as you're
asking this upskilled Smeg board today
and I just wonder if it really requires
that's to happen or that this mag board
we have now could be rejigged a basis is
Roger suggestion but have just an
overall view making sure the money's
there support for whatever is
relationships maintained that sort of
governance that the other functions that
we have of that upskilled Smeg board
stay with the director enters his or her
team at the museum and the satellite
museums thanks Christine I couldn't try
to attempt to answer your question but I
think I think what you're asking for is
a decision that's already being made and
I'll try to in please correct me if I'm
wrong trustees but the purpose of the
document that we have in front of us is
to talk about the repurpose made trust
board looking after the collection the
museum secretly in the director in what
the museum activity will be is it a site
is sorry both young means just walked in
and all his glory from school is that
what sir
excuse me is there anyone else that can
add to that in my mind here it I may be
hearing it very wrong I haven't seen
museum director or Mets other side of it
mentioned in despatches and I'm just
wondering if somebody else pointed out
where the skill spaces the base will
come from for the present meg board
because presumably the skills that are
required for that that board would also
be found within the team and the
director that we will be chosen given
pyramid reopen um quite a number of
things yeah sorry
Queen I think you're raising your hand
and so is Darrin yes I was going to say
I sorry the put a feedback the board
structure has to be balanced so there's
not only museum expertise but also if
you disagreed good governance and in the
case of most trust boards they are
responsible for the hiring or partly
responsible is a partnership obviously
they're in the future between the
council and the board to put in a
director or manager who looks after the
day-to-day organization but the trust
has to maintain the balance of keeping
the strategic plan of the museum on
track making sure they're you know
annual plans and and I think what Roger
has I mean I think the model we're
looking at is a few loopholes in it
however that that's how I feel at the
moment Thank You green Darrin thanks
Tony
I agree that the the role of director
which is really a lead for things
operationally is something that will be
the control of the employer which will
not be smeared and snags roll is a
governance one so we can look at the
areas the roger has suggested in his
support and as document go up how do we
make sure and oversee that that those
functions are being carried out whilst
at the same time fulfilling our major
role which is which is the custodianship
of of the collection I'm not even sure
that strategy would be necessarily our
domain to formulate but to oversee and
check that it meets requirements a board
would need good advice and that's we
have experts in the different fields of
musi ology providing that advice as we
do now the makeup of the the board which
you know from from what's been suggested
as a skills-based border doesn't include
council representatives and and and
that's fine council has a say on things
operationally is really about government
skills so I guess it's the difference in
how I see things from from perhaps what
Christine was suggesting sorry thank you
I just note on their recommendations
that talks about this made should also
have its function set out and I think if
there's clarity around the functions in
this conversation will be a lot easier
but my
Krishna's how does that process occur
who doesn't it is that the Smeg all have
a workshop around it is that the ascetic
council that's going to determine that
because we I feel we do need clarity on
the functions or to go to that to the
next step I think that's a really good
point
invalid question raised and one that I
personally can't answer and I wonder if
we I'm assuming and it's probably very
wrong for me to do but the council end
end councils will come up with a
proposed structure for want of a better
word but I think it's important that
Smeg is contributing to that because we
are currently in that position and how
we do that we felt from the last meeting
was that we commence this discussion
document and then we feed that back to
all councils including heritage so that
collaboratively we get an outcome that's
beneficial for everybody
these seems to be a disconnect from what
I'm hearing at this point in time
because we have handed over the the
governance and management of the museum
activity that now sits with Council we
are now looking is Roger has a clearly
labeled and has document at the
governance makeup of the board who will
look after the collection so they
strategy around the museum activity the
museum delivery the museum redevelopment
the museum employers and staff will sit
with a different port that is not us in
this decision has been one that's been
made and endorsed by Smeg endorsed by
all the other councils so I think if we
can draw that line in focus on the
governance of the collection I think
you'll see that Rogers recommendations
are very like we've said
a good place to start um even sorry make
sure the the next step is for us today
to agree that this discussion document
we circulated amongst the parties for
the feedback that way we're not just
sitting and waiting we're being
proactive putting it out there saying
look this is what we've been thinking
what do you want to add subtract ultra I
mean get back to us by and actually put
some some some time frames around it so
whatever you think is realistic but I
propose say like six weeks which means
it would be back for the meeting not the
next one but the one after but allow our
all councils and other groups to have
had some time to talk about it does that
seem fair I think that's a great
suggestion that you've made evil in the
end if everybody is happy to do that I
think that to move forward we want to
keep the momentum and we definitely want
to make sure that the Smeg ideas are
considered in this new maker for example
one of the recommendations that Roger
had came to board with today was around
you know elected members and whether or
not we should be on a governing board or
they should be on a governing board so I
think if we can get some agreement
together and then send it out to all
councils this excellent progress Gary
okay so I think you are now halfway on
the idea meant here this the snake is
proving its second or third paragraph
the board members would need collect
lips to collectively to have the skills
knowledge experience and attributes to
effectively govern and direct refocus
the refocused organization
this may include professional skills
secret skills an appropriate diversity
of background is not about the
management of the facility it is totally
to do with the governance so we can't
get out down in there and the weeds with
this this is this is a top-down a
governance structure that we are looking
at and I concur with some of the
comments that have been taught to put
around that no we do need to get this
out there but we can't get into the
management side of things this is not
what we're here to discuss it and won't
you
thank you Gary so can I just have can I
go through the document I think that
might be a better way of doing it and
just see where what areas we all will
agree with in what areas we may need a
bit more work on before we send it
through I'm happy to do that in a
workshop because I know it's a big
document there's a lot of
recommendations in and we may need some
time to do that obviously a meeting like
this isn't necessarily a waste the best
time and we're not actually debating the
issue we're just trying to come up with
like is an issue to debate so if
everybody's happy I'd like to leave this
report and let it lay on the table
organize a workshop for Smeg trustees to
come together personally I think that
would be a lot more beneficial and when
we are in a position where we can get
our appropriate social distancing then
we come together and have a look at
these particular recommendations and
starting point that Roger has made how
does everybody feel about that so I'd
like to move that we leave the report on
the table and set up a workshop we're
going to say to that nice green Thank
You Carolyn
I've got a thumbs up from Green and I've
got a Christine on the phone with agree
and everybody seems to agree so I'll put
that motion obviously all those have
already indicated they are in favor
anyone against that wonderful so let's
leave
Neah bit motions carried in move to the
ownership of the Smeg building which
seems to have been an interesting but
almost point I will hand this over to
Roger because it has been driven by
Roger the reports come from me the Smeg
Trust Board requested that we make
contact with Council and ask for the
evidence verification legal opinions as
to how that decision was made or came to
and you would have read the report in
the response from counsel and I'll leave
it open to you for discussion Roger
thank you madam chairman you you will
recall that my anticipation over this
after we read in the newspaper that we
were told that the City Council actually
owned the building was that council must
have obtained a legal opinion but it
transpires that it has not although it
has said that there has been some legal
input from staff and respect to it in
the chief executive of the ICC has
written this letter and she refers to
some historical factors some of these
factors some I would describe as not of
legal importance so much as formal
documents which recognized the status of
ownership of the building others of them
are more consistent with understandings
then determinative of the legal position
for example we notice said that there
were resolutions passed and I sort of
gave the impression that ownership of
the building was with one party or
another there is that is interesting and
it may be consistent with understandings
but it's not determinative there is a
concession that on page two that around
the time of the 1990
the buildings were shown on the board's
accounts I think that is quite
significant because it would tend to
indicate that for the greater part of
the last 20 years the understanding has
been that the the board owned the
building the reason why that becomes
significant is for purposes of
depreciation and otherwise accountants
whether they are employed by the board
or the City Council would almost always
look for some evidence of ownership
before they apply accounting treatments
to major assets like a museum building
so at some point that would appear that
accountants have been satisfied that the
board was entitled to treat the building
as a tone now some other points about
the report either in the first paragraph
miss Headley refers to a specific trust
having been sent up in the 1990s to
build the museum I haven't seen that
document and when I was introduced as a
trustee and given the history of the
museum board there's no reference to
that in the history historical documents
which were provided to me and those ran
for quite some pages and just by
comparison there was a reference in 1959
to a meeting between the museum Trust
Board and the I calorie trust and 6,000
pounds at that stage was paid into the
museum boards Building Fund so it would
appear that the board had a building
fund for buildings at that time so all
I'm really saying as Miss Headley may
may be correct she may not it's
difficult to know it's the sort of
subject which I think should be the
subject of our a proper legal opinion
but at the end of all this I think the
board has to consider what it should do
now it could just let the whole metal
lie because the building or collection
of buildings is probably a liability
rather than an essay it now
and to what purpose would we pursue an
inquiry for example we could call from
our own legal opinion or we could do
some further research ourselves I I
might be able to find out a bit more
which would be useful the the chief
executive says will come back to me if
you've got an alternative view so we
could do that but whether it's all going
to serve a useful purpose or not I have
some I have some doubts because we're
not going to be able to do anything with
the building ourselves the building is
probably going to be demolished and a
new building will be created so part of
the my exasperation over this is really
the one which it has come to being
brought to our notice we might have
thought that if there's been an
understanding for the best part of 20
years that the museum board owned the
building we might have received some
private communication from the city
about that rather than reading it in
public but I don't want to let that
overcome our common sense as to whether
it should be pursued further so I I'm
happy to go with whatever the board
decides us to the next step that I am a
I'm unsatisfied as a lawyer with that
letter if that is the sole basis on
which it said that the City Council owns
the museum buildings you Roger I
appreciate the work in the effort that's
gone into that from your perspective
especially is a trustee of the board any
questions discussion comments Gary well
I feel your pain Roger this is a
historical matter I think the chief
executive and staff have done what they
can I understand this is the only one
building and under Cagle that is in
question
Christine means has agree with me we
have roads toppings we hit buildings we
hit properties coming across their table
just to death every two three months
where there's an argument over who owns
what and where when we go back into the
eight late 1800s and 1900s trying to
establish it over a hall or a wife sheet
or a piece of land or a triangle on the
road
if we went to get legal advice on all of
this we would be broke and no disrespect
to lawyers but we would be broke
personally I think you've got to take
the guidance from the chief executive
and staff she is the chief executive for
the embarkation City Council I
understand it's gone to Council I don't
know what else we could do and as you
say is it a piece of infrastructure that
may not be there in time to come and we
spend a few thousand dollars trying to
establish it so I think we've got to
take a step back from this and realize
that will not realize but except that
the building itself has under the
control of the end of Carol City Council
some of you can you can I come is this
yeah please person yes of course
thanks very the way I read clear loser
it was obviously in the 1956 after
centennial that they the Finance
Committee listed the City Council with
money as uniform bit major celebration
when Bobby was second the fakeness City
Council owned at the building is makes
practical sense because it's in the
council area but it was as I read
through the rest of the documents it's
on behalf of cylinders so this is where
I think the very immediate ASAP
consultation about the future the
pyramid is so important it just because
it's owned by the council doesn't mean
it has say over the future and it really
has to go back to the ratepayers of in
the Carroll and self and to look at any
proposals post covert 19 while we're
steering in the face a major worldwide
economic depression and just work out
what we want of from that building
demolishing it probably won't be an
option because it costs a lot of money
to do that and I think the jury is out
on the future of that building until we
ask the people of south
what they want and any ideas we had for
big expensive showcase buildings he has
to be has to be put put to one side
while we contemplate the economics of
not only those sorts of rebuilds but
also what's happening around not only in
the caracal the rest of New Zealand in
the rest of the world and put that in
perspective so we cut act out according
to the cloth so I think we're getting a
little bit too far ahead I think
ownership at this stage is probably a
moot point it's what happens to that
building and that people of the south
and want that should dictate what we do
next in whatever financial or
aspirational or historic movement that
we make so I would rather see this these
ideas incorporated in the consultation
and document to be sent out to the
public looking at all these it also in
even including post workshop that we
have Tony's the governance structure and
whether we want a manager in charge of
the museum or a museum director who
knows about museum sorry Christine thank
you um I think what I've heard from you
again is sadly going back to an area
which is not our mandate to consider so
I just want to pull back a little and
ask you if in relevance to the document
that you have in front of you about the
ownership of the building are you happy
for are you happy for it to lay where it
is or would you like to see a legal
opinion about the ownership of the
building or are you asking for
consultation to the community about the
ownership because the other things that
you've referenced are not in our control
I think ownership responsibility but the
responsibility
the City Council on behalf of all
cylinders so it's really good has to go
back to yeah so ownership is just a what
are your technical things it's not it
doesn't imply overall being in charge of
its future
it just it's really just looking after
on behalf of others for that we've you
don't want to see the do you would you
like to see the process of the ownership
followed up or are you quite happy to
leave it where it is weren't lay I just
I think just just told him the band's
we've got far more important things to
think about
great thank you thank you very much
thank you thank you if I'm ready I'm
having a move the recommendation don't
you thank you Gary we've got a moment
select recommendation but I hear someone
in the background much wasn't you pull
in that's Jamie here can you hear me hi
Jamie hi it just to add to the counting
side I have done a bit of work research
with Kimberly and windy and why that
we've got a building and land on our
successes schedule so it's gone back to
1995 and there was a change of an
accounting policy back then and it
brought on 75% of the government
evaluation for the land and buildings
now what it's important to note here is
the land cannot be owned by anyone but
the council because it is reserve Lane
so I'm not quite sure why these even
land on a fixed asset schedule which
kind of questions why the buildings here
I can't we haven't found anything else
backing up why they got brought on but
it's just didn't know that it was a Kemp
and an accounting policy change been to
bring those on for some reason but we
can't take any further than that sorry
no it's really valuable Jamie thank you
very much a Gary you've moved a
recommendation I think Evelyn wanted to
speak to there
yes madam chair I think it I don't want
to see us investing any more money in
time and chasing this particular rabbit
down a hole because I think the whatever
we have contributed as a board
financially to parts of the complex is
irrelevant now the complex as it is is
not is no longer safe and set for
purpose so if we want to as board assume
the financial responsibility for
repairing it I'm sure the council will
be immensely grateful but we would find
the money from I don't know I think this
is the tricky part with a historic
building said have been added to and
altered and mended in different people
put money towards that and all those
sorts of things that what we're faced
with now is the board is that what we
thought was an SAH that we owned
probably as not really ever being truly
ours and it is totally a liability so I
want us to leave the other side get on
with what we can work on which as you
know as much as we are able to the
future directions and I'm grateful to
roger for the work that he's done I find
it interesting what's in here and I
think Jamie for his contribution as well
because there actually makes a little
bit more sense than my head as to hell
because I keep thinking that we cannot
possibly own any part of Queens Park
because of here's a legal identity of
its own which it cannot be alienated and
so that explains that accounting things
are
three to me but I know that they happen
so I would like to think in what what
Gary is saying that we yeah
we accept what has been seared we don't
put any more money or time and to be
suing it it's of a caddy I can trust but
it's not going to change the fix thank
you Thank You Evelyn um I've got a
motion that's been put in seeking debts
Darren thanks to it so historically
everyone's quite right you know that the
museum is on Queens Park which is
reserved land and there was no way we
could ever own that from when I came
onto the board
it was simply accepted as an
understanding that we owned the building
and were custodian of the contents but
we knew we did not own the land and we
was had to pay a rental for their each
year and I think from a trustee
perspective we were right to seek
confirmation that we could read a
pathway of that shows how actually it
appears the building wasn't as and but
we can see a pathway and there which we
could go and have peer reviewed by a
lawyer but you know no one's got a great
appetite for spinning that but we've
we've we've done our duty yeah and and
checked we can see a pathway and we can
go okay well it appears we might never
have owned the building and certainly
from my position here now and 2020 we're
not really sure we want to given its
current condition so happy to see things
move ahead from this point with the
comfort that from the last meeting we
asked for a bill proof we've got it
thank you I feel that we've got a motion
on the floor it's been moved and
seconded
Christine before we move into it putting
there could you please repeat the motion
thank you
sure so the recommendation
and this report are that the report
ownership of Smeg building the pyramid
be received in the Southland Museum
transport are satisfied that the
ownership of the pyramid building
belongs with the council in that our SC
registered financial records are updated
to reflect this it's been moved and
seconded before I put the motion I
always consider the people prior to us
and what they would be feeling right now
having this call it away and I just want
to acknowledge Russell beak in as far
know who put the hours and hours blood
sweat and tears of of work and into this
building and I hate to hear that being
argued about in this way so to speak so
my acknowledgment to him we've done
great due diligence thinking Roger I
appreciate it everyone is happy to move
forward but just needed to make sure
that he is considered in this
conversation because I don't want him to
me
so now Mohito roger in far too - Russell
Inferno and let's close up here I'll
move that public motion to the floor
everyone in favor say aye aye against
carries wonderful guys thank you very
much okay and finally our financial
reports from Jamie okay alright so what
you've got in front of you is the
financials for cap to the end of April
I'm showing a profit of just just under
$9,000
so we've had minimal transactions for
the last few months just the management
fee and the grants we receive mainly
we're still likely to in up in a loss
situation for the year once the order
fee comes in but there is to be expected
so it's really the month lease it's not
too much to talk about the air we've got
one payment to authorize which is listed
the year as well and we've also got to
term deposit which we've got up for
renewal for the book request funds
so 222,000 we'll just over there at the
moments maturing so we just need
confirmation of what term life the board
would like to go for assuming we want to
roll over the term deposit I'm
suggesting 180 days again the
foreseeable future I don't see we walk
we do have some of those funds just
sitting in our call account so it's got
easy access so yeah I don't see any and
the issue locking at the end for another
six months
okay the recommendations on the report
is it the monthly financial report for
the ten months ended 30 April 2020 be
received in the payments for
authorization be approved I'm happy to
move those if it is in here Sikandar out
fear thanks counselor that way all those
in favor aye
against carry now I just want to go back
to Jamie do you need a decision made
today read it about the term deposit
tree sorry he's just as long as it's
done by ideally today and that by the
end of the month when they actually have
to see in the instructions away thank
you are you recommending the 180 days is
the appropriate way to go moving forward
yes there'll be my recommendation okay
I based on the fact that you are a
financial adviser and Evelyn I'll take
thank you so I'm here to move that we
follow that recommendation 180 days at
2.2% seeking goodbye Everland all those
in favor
he might carry cup i Thank You Jamie
cool
um we've got a statement of an intent
on as item 6.2 the recommendations are
that the statement of intent has
received the statement of intent as
improved in the statement of intent be
issued to stakeholders ICC in District
Council we have all gone through the
statement of intent before so this is
ratifying basically what we had draft
and anticipated for adoption there's any
questions or discussion on the statement
of intent just so everyone knows I've
made a couple small changes so I've
taken out the building ownership roof
front reference so that I've taken that
out that was was page three the twelve
it was a separate bullet point so I've
taken their out and I've also added
financial forecasts now that's based on
our business as usual approach but that
will likely change once the governance
is sorted out and the functions any
questions about the statement of intense
discussion points comments Tony it's
Paul here
I'm really sorry to even say it because
I hate people coming along with the last
minute with some bright idea that they
should have actually thought of earlier
on so and it's such a small thing but in
the vision statement I said he would
talk about a master family experience
which is great but I just wonder given
the number of people who live on their
own nowadays and so on if there is a wee
bit you know not inclusive enough
perhaps you raise a very good point I
mean it was interesting that this was
discussed some time ago and we've sort
of been in this holding patient but if
we look at the new presence in their
city in the in their and then the
part-time Museum and Art Gallery we'll
call it the transitional space I'm
looking at managers they're coming to
give me smack on the hand and trying to
find the right words
it must be inclusive for everybody so I
would be happy to form in that do you
have a suggestion I just wonder for ease
of just to take the word family out but
someone else might have a better idea I
mean we could spend an afternoon on it
and still not that's better but just I
just wonder I just make that suggestions
I'm just going to wait Queen in me and I
think we've got Christine on the phone
we have a large community yeah we would
include them all we want to include them
all in anyone else visiting no Tony I'm
not unhappy with it at all I think
that's a legacy from ICC's
family-friendly branding for everyone is
just fine for the people of South
Christine Christine are you on the phone
here did you want to go Christine means
like where I get this Christine Anderson
here just just put visitors it covers
everyone local provincial national
international Thank You Christine
mimzy's I'm just suggesting between
because there is discussion about the
board being different and makeup this is
an exercise the new board would go
through rather than us try to find a
different word right now without
thinking through all the implications
that covers everything okay I'm makes
that a must to experience and to me that
says it all it's it is totally inclusive
I'm just as likely or to go to a museum
or an art gallery or a library by myself
I don't see it necessarily involving
taking along a child or whatever and
just deleting one word makes that makes
it inclusive fine you can come along and
get my children and take them next time
I shall if the recommendations and see
what the broader feeling and remove the
word family in that way I think it
covers everyone's requirements today I
mean it gives a good State for the new
board whatever that looks like and then
in the future moving forward thank you
for the suggestion poll all those in
favor or do I have a seconder for those
motions first recommendations I think
you Guin
all those in favor favor and you always
carries thank you everybody
Thank You Jamie tow for all the work
that you've done on the statement and
statement of intent for us it makes the
end of the public part of our meaning so
we'll move that we move into public
excluded if Queens happy to seek a net
by waving at me
actually Tony can we go back to the to
the action sheet please I missed it
because I was late I did speak with Tony
Davis wonderful yeah really we hit
crossing but however we did communicate
and decided that once we were over
covered we would meet with the family
and have a chat about what was
appropriate Oh lovely that sounds
fantastic thank you for updating us on
that thank you very much um you know I'm
just looking to you now because I need a
lead I've moved that we
move into public excluded I've got a
second definite motion all those in
favor aye
carried in a lot to you you know so you
can